alright everyone welcome to the webinar
today we're going to be talking about a
new functionality within the utilities
API that supports accession version
identifiers we do have materials for
this webinar the power point as well as
a couple of the little bells and
whistles that I'll talk about later will
be available for you on the ftp site and
you can get to that ftp site at the
courses in webinars page link on the
screen here and also there's a direct
link to the ftp site at the go usa.gov
URL alright so with all of that said i'm
going to go ahead and and start webinar
so what we're talking about today this
is actually the fourth webinar in a
series of webinars about changes that
have been going on with the way that
ncbi deals with sequins identifiers and
today we are happy to announce that the
e-utilities our main api for the entree
system is now able to fully support
accession version identifiers both an
input and an output so what i want to do
is basically give you a quick overview
of how that works and then point you to
some examples so as i said we have been
doing webinars about this since this
past summer I back in July there's three
webinars we've already put out there
about various topics relevant to the
changes in identifiers for sequence
records here at NCBI so feel free to go
back and take a look at those if you
haven't had a chance to do them in very
short and sweet the change that's
happening is that gradually in CBI is
facing out an identifier called AGI
number these are integer identifiers
that have been used for many years for
sequences but for a number of reasons we
are phasing those out and transitioning
to a situation where we will be using
accession version identifiers as the
primary identifier for sequence records
since so many of our tools including the
e-utilities has been dependent upon GI
numbers in the past it was critical for
us to be able to offer these AP is an a4
firm that would not be dependent upon
GIS but would be dependent upon a
different identifiers that the
accessions up version so the main thing
that we've introduced is a parameter
called ID type that will control this in
the e-utilities and it works a little
bit differently in the various utilities
now go through summary fetch search link
and then the final kind of a little
prize packet at the end how you get
sequences that don't have GIS and what's
that about and how can you think about
that problem going forward so let me
just review quickly again a little bit
more detail about what's changing so
that everyone's on the same page the GI
numbers are being phased out what this
means is they're not being deleted it's
really important for people to
understand that we're not deleting GI
numbers we are just not going to assign
GI numbers to a growing number of newly
deposited sequences so if you have a
sequence that has a GI number it will
continue to have that GI number and will
always be retrievable by that GI number
for the foreseeable future so what's
happening though as more and more new
studies come in those will not be
assigned GI numbers and so you will if
you stick with just GI space you won't
have access to more and more of the new
data that are coming in so a few things
that have already been happening or that
the GI numbers are no longer visible on
the flat file formats on the web or in
fast a definition lines including for
example in the blasts fast a databases
so you won't see the GI numbers in those
presentations and again just to be clear
the GI numbers are still in the raw data
file so for example the asn.1 or the xml
but they will not be shown in those more
public web friendly presentations after
march 15 to this year none of the
releases of GenBank or refseq will
contain GI numbers in their
presentations in the flat file or in the
fast day presentations that you get off
the FTP site so that's another thing
just to be aware of so that's what's
happening now let's talk about the
e-utilities
what effect this has on them for those
of you who aren't as familiar I wanted
to just quickly go over what the
utilities are and what they do and their
function and how they depend upon a
unique identifier all right for any
database now the e-utilities work in all
of the entree databases from pubmed you
know through the sequence databases to
genetics medical day to day basis
whatever it would be utilities function
of ross a wide variety of identifier
spaces so what they do is a few
functions so ii search which we show at
the top basically can take a text query
whatever text that might be in terms and
then return back to you a set of these
unique identifiers that correspond to
the result result set those unique
identifiers or you IDs can then be
passed to additional utilities to
retrieve those records so for example I
can pass a UID to East summary to get
the record summary or the docs um this
is a short abbreviated metadata about a
record that you commonly see a search
result on the web in entre alternatively
I could take a UID and pass it to e
fetch which would download the full data
record in a variety of formats so pubmed
you can get abstract citation medline
etc asn.1 xml for sequences you can get
fast a flat file xml ls1 etc so fetch is
a great utility for getting the data
down right once you have identifiers in
hand elink is another powerful utility
that lets you take identifiers from a
given database and find linked records
in another database so for example I
want to find the PubMed literature
associated with the sequence I could
link from the sequence record to PubMed
I could link from nucleotide to protein
etc etc so link also talks in this UID
space so one set of you IDs in another
set of you I'd ezel finally epost is the
little utility there's essentially an
upload utility that takes you ids and
puts them on to a temporary storage
facility that we call the entree
three and this is a ncbi server that
stores temporarily your search results
so then i can take the results from that
entrée history and pass those to fetch
or to summary or to link for further
processing so I think it's pretty clear
as you look at the diagram that all of
these utilities either output you IDs or
accept you i Jesus input so it's
absolutely critical to the function of
this API that the I do ID space be well
determined so for sequence records and
we're talking about nucleotide protein
EST and dss databases and pop set the
UID has always been the GI number right
the integer identifier not anymore right
you can continue doing that but now all
of these utilities will do the same
thing for accession dot version that's a
very powerful upgrade in the
functionality of these AP is and it also
extends their scope significantly and
we'll talk more about that towards the
end so again the set of you ID now is a
set of accession but version identifiers
you have the option it's important to
understand you can continue to use GI
numbers you have the option to use
accession version and again I listed
there the primary databases that this
affects with this change so let's step
through them and just talk about what
would happen so luckily a summary and
fetch kind of get an upgrade that's
silent so generally with e summary and
sets you use the ID parameter as input
all right for the you IDs so in the
first URL I'm showing their East summary
and the databases new core there's two
you IDs there right that's a traditional
Isom recall for a fetch would be the
same kind of call saying you IDs but I
might quit rent type equals fast a to
specify that I want the fast paced
format what you can do now right is
instead of using those integer
identifiers the GIS you can put
accession right accession versions if
you put an accession without a version
you
the most recent version of that
accession right so that just works you
don't have to do anything else to your
call you don't have to add an ID type
parameter or anything else it just works
so this is great you can just start
using this all right now for those of
you who've been using these api's you
may realize that effect is actually been
able to do this for many years you fetch
has been able to accept accession
versions for several years along with
GIS it continues to do that so really in
this regard eh has not changed the
summary has changed the summary has
never been able to accept accessions as
input it can now right so that's what's
happening with these summary any such
pretty simple don't have to do anything
you can just use accessions now you
search now e search is a little bit more
interesting because what research now
can do is output data as accession
version so what AE search does is takes
a text query like fox p2 title and human
organism I don't want the human
sequences for Fox p2 fine before I would
assemble this call what that would give
me and as well show you in a minute is a
list of GI numbers back what it does now
is you have the option if you add the ID
type parameter and you give it the value
ack ACC for accession so if i eat ID
equals ack is appended to that same
search call you'll get something
different here's what you get different
so the default without using ID type
these are going to get back a list of by
default top 20 GI numbers unique
identifiers that match your query right
so those would be nucleotide GIS but if
you use ID type equals back what you get
back are the accession duck versions so
this is cool you get the accession
versions as if the GIS don't exist right
and so you just get them back directly
and then you can use them in further
processing elink is going to behave in
much the same way right so II link again
take sets of identifiers as input and
then gives you set
of identifiers as output in the same or
a different database so a very simple
example is here's a nucleotide GI number
I want to find the protein that it
encodes so I say DD front equals new
core DB equals protein there's my ID I
would expect to get back the protein GI
all right that's associated with this if
I use ID type equals back and append
that to the URL now what it allows me to
do our two things I can have an
accession number as input right so I
don't have to use a GI can use the
accession and I will get back accessions
in the output so here's a comparison of
the xml that I would get back from those
two calls if ID type is not set and if
you can just put this in the URL if it's
not set the default is essentially GI
all right so it will give you back GI
numbers so here is my new core DB from
here is the ID in new core link is to
protein here is the ID number for
protein 3457 7063 right so that's the GI
of the protein that's linked to the
incoming new core record but if I use ID
type equals act which you see on the
right side is that my NM record 0 0 1
126 is now linked to NP 0 0 1 1 1 7 dot
too so I get the accessions back
immediately all right so ID type equal
zach is required for e search and a link
if you want to get the accessions in the
output now finally before we do a little
bit of playing with this I want to talk
about some expanded scope that the
utilities now have access to because of
this change and it's important to
understand this so that you don't run
afoul of the way the data are structured
now and be aware that these changes will
continue to happen as things progress we
have sequences that don't have G is
right and that's an issue for a number
of reasons because a sequence without a
GI is not part of the entree system so
it's not part of entre nucleotide new
core or entree protein or any other
entre
database which has several consequences
a search cannot find them they're not
indexed in entre so II search has no
access to them they do not have document
summaries they're not an entree so a
summary cannot retrieve them they have
no entre links so II link is useless you
can't perform links between G eyeless
objects right in anything else they're
simply not in the system and also they
cannot be placed on the entree history
so for example epost cannot handle or
process them for those of you who are
utility aficionados if you use e search
with youth history equals why it won't
work for a gif sequence because they
can't be put on the history they're not
part of on train but all right 'if etch
can now download them so a fetch has
become an odd man out and that it now
has a special function that it has
access to the whole world of g i love
sequences through their accession dot
version all in cbi sequences whether
they have a GI number or not have an
accession that version identifier fetch
now can access all of them this is brand
new functionality that we have never had
before that api access to all of these
GI list sequences that still do have an
accession dot version so what are we
talking about a lot of w GS and a lot of
tsa so whole genome shotgun data sets
and transcriptome shotgun assembly data
sets many of these data sets do not have
g is for their context they may have a
GI number for their master record that
they will not in many cases have gi
numbers for all the context and
ultimately most new sequences eventually
almost all new sequences will be like
this they will not have gi numbers they
will have an accession about version so
it's important to understand this is
kind of the future and if where things
are moving so that accession version
becomes the main I
a fire that you become to depend on a a
cardinal example of the state currently
is the Norway spruce project that is CB
VK this is a very large project with
over a million context because of the
size of that project it was not assigned
GI numbers so it has one GI number that
represents the master record so CD DK
and all those zeros that single
representative record which has by the
way no data in it except metadata that
one record is indexed and entree so if
you were to go search for Norway spruce
and on trade nucleotide you would find
that record but all of the million
context that are really where the data
are that are part of that project are
not available to you for monitoring and
have not been able to be available to
you from the API the utilities they are
now all right so one question that folks
might have is how do i check if a
sequence has a GI number or not and the
easy way to do this programmatically is
to use East summary because each summary
will immediately returned to you an
error tag telling you this accession
does not have an identifier a GI
identifier and you can do that with a
mixed bag of input and each summary will
very politely tell you which one's work
and which ones don't so at this point
that's our recommendation as to the best
way to check the summary is very fast it
can process thousands of records in a
given URL so it's a good way to parse
through a big list if you want to really
find out what has a GI and / or not it's
a reasonable approach there are other
approaches if you have massive projects
and you're concerned about using a
summary right to us talk to us we can
give you some additional advice so what
I'm going to do now before I go to the
stay tuned slide is do a little bit of
demo haha the live demo okay so what
we're going to do here is just go
through a few calls just that you can
see how they work and also this little
Perl scripts an incredibly simple will
perl script i put on the ftp site in k
you want to play with it or just explore
the calls a little bit i'm going to
actually show you what the perl script
looks like that's it just so you can see
all it does is it post the URL and I
have a little array here at eight sample
URLs I'm just going to go through very
quickly but you can explore this edit
this as you want and play with these
functionality so the first URL is need
summary URL that's going to get back to
sequence records specified by an
accession right this is something that
we haven't been able to do in the past
right so to run this little perl script
i just say pearl get URL pearl that's
the first URL its index is one I do that
I get some data so what you see here are
two doc some records right the first one
here and the nice thing is that it works
in the past this would have given an
error so that works i get my accession
back I get my record back for those of
you who are parsing docs firms you might
want to be aware that we have a new tag
within the doc sums called accession
version right that thing's brand new and
it has the accession about version in it
so that's that you can parse out
directly alright that's where the
identifier is now of course the GI
number is going to be there also and
again if it doesn't have a GI you
somebody can't find it so the GI number
is going to be there all right so that's
how a summary is going to work you
searched right to e search calls one is
going to look for fox p2 title and human
organism without ID type equals act the
other one has ID type equals back
appended alright so let's do the first
one right so as i was showing the slides
this is what i get back i get 48 things
back here's the top 20 I get GI numbers
all right all i have to do is add that
excited I pickles ACK and that URL and I
get back the accessions okay you can do
the head with that all right going on a
lake so now we'll do a link the way we
just did he search linking from a new
core record to a protein record here's
the ID
it's also in m 001 126 alright so we'll
do it both ways just knowing I have to
include ID x equals a cat the end as I'm
going to do the accession right so my
first elane call again has the GI number
as input gives me the GI number is
output for the protein right if i do ID
type equals ack here's the nms the input
the NP is the output very nice alright
so and again you can do this if you're
linking across from non sequence the
sequence databases so if I'm going from
PubMed into new core or pubmed into
protein use ID type equals act and of
course pubmed will not have an accession
number right that's fine the ideal use
p.m. ids as your input to a link but the
output from ealing will be accession
numbers in protein space all right so
that will all work just fine alright
let's take a look at the last ones here
here's fetch right here are some of that
wonderful Norway spruce data alright so
this is wgs data that we simply has not
been able to give you before with fetch
so that URL just new cord here's the ID
the long accession right the accession
for the contig i'm going to get fast
stay back hopefully right that's what
I'd like to do so I do that boom ok
there's the fast day for that wgs contig
if i scroll up to the top of it here it
is there it is pc IDs there's the data
it has a contact name so all this little
fascinate definition line is something
we're providing to you I mean it doesn't
exist in on train but we're providing
one to you and so there it is you can
get those data now it's very likely that
if you want the entire project ftp might
be a better method but this is a way
that you can get contact by contig if
you particularly want to get a set of
contacts down from one of these sets
last but not least a summary as a check
alright so how do i check to see whether
my gianna my sequence has a GI number so
i'm going to try e summary with the CBD
k my bed at same accession i just
reached
with the bench going to try that and see
what happens then I'm going to try it in
the mix of the mixed list of other
things an in and record and a genbank
record how would it how would it look if
I had a mixed list and I had a bomb in
there right it doesn't have a GI number
what is he summary going to do so a
summary in the case where I just give it
that Norway spruce wgs contig very
politely tells me error invalid uid at
this position all right so I know that's
the contact that had no you ID all right
pretty short and simple if i give it
those three identifier two of which have
GIS one doesn't this is the data that i
get back at the top again you see error
invalid uid there it is at this position
and then I get the two valid doc sums
back as expected so this should be a
fairly rapid way to quickly check a list
of data to say what has GIS want us so
again this little perl script it's very
almost brainlessly simple perl script
it's on the ftp sites that you can play
with that if you want and again if you
have questions about any of that will be
taking them in a couple of moments or
you have questions later please don't
hesitate to write to us so that will be
my last little statement before I be
quiet and we'll start discussing
continue to follow our our social media
posts our blog our news are our Facebook
and Twitter accounts for more updates
and announcements about things will be
happening with these sequence resources
the changes with the identifier space
going forward the NCA I learned page is
a great place to come for events like
this if you want to have more awareness
of the webinars and other courses that
we're offering if you want to find out
about utility updates and this is a
great idea if you're using them please
subscribe to utilities announced at NCBI
that's where we send out all the
announcements about these upcoming
changes how you need to be prepared for
them where we announce in advance the
changes are happening so it's a great
place to look for those kinds of things
and keep yourself aware and not be
surprised and then finally info at NCBI
is
general help desk please don't hesitate
to write to us if you have questions or
concerns alright so I'm going to be
quiet at the moment and open the floor
to questions okay hi this is Peter
Cooper um we do have a couple of
questions Erick so several of them I
answered and you sort of answer them as
you went through so i'm not going to go
over those again those are the ones they
answered in the questions pod and
interestingly people ask those questions
immediately you said the answer to them
so here's a few others the first one is
about downloading wgf sequences from the
ftp site actually given a top-level wgs
project ID so that's essentially that
prefix what's the best way to
programmatically get the ftp location
for the entire assembly so one way that
you can do that is to use the bio
project database that is a good place to
search for these datasets that has
metadata in it that will allow you to
find the project that is the source of
the wgs data you can link from bio
project into new core and that will give
you the master record if it's not in the
bio project data itself that's one
Avenue and then you would be able to
construct an ftp URL down to the ftp
site to get that data from from genbank
another way that you could approach that
task of getting the appropriate
accession is through new core itself at
this point my understanding is that all
of our wgs product projects release the
vast majority of them will be assigned a
GI number for their master record and
that master record would be index with
some metadata so if you're trying to
search by organism when you're trying to
search by a title or something like that
of the project you should be able maybe
able to find it that way and then you
can construct an ftp RL into genbank I
hope that helps I mean if you want more
detail on that let us know and we can
provide you with some additional
suggestion yeah i think the ftp to
structure the ftp site is a formal way
of doing it based on those exceptions
and so what I'll do is I'll put that in
the
I have to look at it so I can describe
it properly I'll put that in the queue a
document so everybody can take a look at
that I'm the other question that I see
your eric is kenny summary maintain the
order of the input uid even if there is
a gif accession version in there it's a
good question and one that we were
thinking about a little bit honestly
ourselves at the moment what's happening
is that the order should be maintained
for those records that do have G is it
appears to what's happening is we're
rotting the errors at the top of the
output stream so that's a lil bit of a
disruption in the current order of the
input so that's a good suggestion we'll
take that up with our development staff
and see if we can do something to
address that but at the moment I think
you're going to be stuck with finding
the errors in the top and then the rest
of them should be in the order that you
submit them d summer all right well
thank you all very much for your time
and for attending good luck out there
and again let us know if you run into
problems or concerns or have suggestions
about these new functions thank you very
much and have a great day